un bonsoir à tous lors du 7-8 journal
sur tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité à locale en 26 minutes
nous sommes le mercredi 19 septembre
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition les motards sensibiliser au
chesnay la police nationale des yvelines
organiser des ateliers pédagogiques
gratuits une action à quelques jours de
l'automne essayez danger supplémentaire
avant l'automne la période estivale a
été marquée par une nette baisse du
nombre de tués sur les routes nous en
parlons avec notre invité à la ryder cup
débute dans moins d'une semaine avec six
ans avec 60000 spectateurs qui viendront
chaque jour sur place le trafic sera
forcément impactées à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération a établi un plan de
transport explications à suivre enfin
comme chaque mercredi nous nous rendons
dans les salles de cinéma saint
quentinois ce soir celle signer cet
appel en cours qui nous propose sa
sélection de la semaine à retrouver dès
aujourd'hui à la fiche à l'eau en
septembre dernier le maire jeter l
éponge ce soir se tient le premier
conseil municipal de coignières depuis
la démission de jean-pierre sevestre à
l'ordre du jour pas de désignation
encore d'un nouvel édile est la
préfecture n'a pas acté pour le moment
par écrit cette décision la séance
devrait être conduite par dominique
catelin première adjointe qui assure
l'intérim depuis une semaine
et si d'aventuré ce soir c'est l'un des
scénarios possibles neuf conseillers
venait à démissionner une élection
municipale partielle devra se tenir dans
la commune
on n'a qu'à une autre a invité sur ce
plateau jean yves petit bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur du comité des
yvelines de l'association as prévention
routière avec vous on va parler de
plusieurs sujets dans un instant regarde
d'abord ce reportage ensemble et
policiers motocyclistes des yvelines ont
donné rendez vous aux chaînés samedi
dernier pour des ateliers pédagogiques
gratuits au programme de la journée des
parcours pis des ateliers route et même
à des séances de secourisme une action à
quelques jours du début de l'automne
avec ses feuilles mortes sur la route et
ses nuits qui cela rend qui sera l'enjeu
sont à des dangers supplémentaires pour
les motards isabelle karisko ce
contrairement aux apparences ces
motocyclistes de la police nationale
n'effectue pas un contrôle
ce samedi au chesnay ils ont donné
rendez vous aux moteurs yvelinois pour
une journée d'ateliers pédagogiques
objectif de ce premier parcours pis de
la journée revoir les bases de la
conduite du dos rond ça permet de voir
que tous les défauts que l'on à quoi ça
permet de les corriger
oui ça peut ça peut sauver des vies si
on connaît bien la machine avec ses
ateliers gratuits la police espère
corriger les comportements davantage
responsables des accidents mortels que
l'alcool ou la vitesse
l'objectif c'est de le faire que les
participants le fasse avec leurs propres
photos persos de façon à mieux connaître
eux aussi leur moto ça peut lors d'un
événement particulier
la conduite est vite et éventuellement
justement un accident en ayant des
mauvais réflexe due à des mauvais
réflexe en tout cas ils ont aussi plus
le même regard sur leur propre conduite
et celle des autres autre atelier
proposé le secourisme les participants
apprennent à gérer une situation
tristement courante les gestes à
connaître face à une personne accidentée
il ya très peu de pourcentage de la
population qui a passé le pc qui se
connaît les gestes de secourisme donc
c'est plus qu'utile et on se rend compte
que si les gens connaissent et les gens
savent il ya on peut tout simplement
sauver des vies les gendarmes et les crs
se sont associés à la police pour cette
journée de prévention ludique dont le
but est avant tout de lutter contre
l'insécurité routière en 2017 40000
personnes dont quatorze motards ont
perdu la vie sur les routes des yvelines
jean yves petit directeur du comité des
yvelines de l'association prévention
routière avec nous sur ce plateau
l'arrivée de l'automne et les
changements de saisons en général c'est
son ce sont des périodes à risque parce
que les conditions de route évolué dans
ce sens là oui quand c'est du printemps
vers l'été il n'y a pas à pas tellement
de changements mais avec l'automne oui
les feuilles qui vont tomber la pluie
qui va qui va retomber donc
effectivement les routes vont être
probablement un peu plus glissantes
donc effectivement il ya quelques
risques est ce que c'est à un moment du
coup pour votre association de re faire
de la pédagogie
faire des sensibilisations sur sur les
comportements les réflexes à adopter
c'était toute l'année un bien sûr toute
l'année donc le changement là dans
quelques jours l'arrivée de l'automne
ça va pas changer fondamentalement mon
travail dans l'ansé toute l'année avec
l'auteur avant l'automne pardon il ya eu
bien sûr l'été la période estivale a été
marquée par une nette baisse du nombre
de tués sur les routes françaises - 15,5
pour cent en août par rapport à la même
période l'an passé à -5 5% en juillet ce
sont des chiffres satisfaisants à bas ce
sont des chiffres encourageants et à
vrai dire c'est comme ça un peu depuis
le début de l'année 1
l'année est loin d'être finie bien sûr
mais depuis le début de l'année ce sont
des chiffres encourageants avec
toutefois un petit bémol pour l'été là
et surtout le mois d'août
puisqu'il ya eu une baisse très
importante du nombre de tués c'est vrai
mais il ya eu une recrudescence du
nombre de tués piétons et cyclistes que
j'explique d'une façon assez simple
il a fait tellement beau pendant cet été
tout le monde le sait bien que les
piétons et les cyclistes sont
certainement sorti beaucoup plus que
quand il pleut donc plus de monde sur la
voie publique
et fatalement plus d'accidents vous le
disiez plusieurs mois consécutifs de
baisse est ce que ça veut dire que les
perspectives sont encourageantes pour
les prochains mois envoyez oui oui je
pense qu'il faut l'espérer oui oui je ne
sais pas si nous atteindrons le niveau
record de tuer enfin à la baisse de 2013
mais nous repartons dans la bonne
direction a priori joue par m'engager
trop tôt mais ça semble plutôt bien
partis quand même et à quoi faut-il la
tribu et ce selon vous cette baisse
alors vous savez qu'il ya eu un comité
interministériel de la sécurité routière
au mois de janvier on va reparler je
suggère à l'heure et avec la mesure
phare du 80 kilomètres heure qui a fait
beaucoup de débats depuis le début de
l'année donc depuis le début de l'année
on peut dire que la sécurité routière
est revenu un peu sur le devant de la
scène médiatique au moins et
je pense que ça aider nos concitoyens à
repenser un peu sécurité ou des reprises
de jeunes france je pense je pense oui
vous parliez de cette mesure de 81 km
heure une limitation baisse de
limitation à 80 km/heure depuis le 1er
juillet sur les axes secondaires sans
séparateur central est ce que c'est une
conséquence directe selon vous cette
baisse de la mortalité ou cesser trop
tôt encore pour tirer une conclusion en
balance je suis quand même beaucoup trop
tôt en deux mois on peut pas on peut pas
tirer des conclusions en anges préférés
rien dire là-dessus
attendons mais constatons simplement que
depuis le début de l'année les chiffres
sont plutôt encourageants en tout cas
l'une des des eaux de l'un des objectifs
pardon du gouvernement s'étaient
endiguer justement à l'annoncé de cette
mesure est la mortalité sur les routes
quel premier bilan vous tirez c'est vrai
que c'est difficile encore de tirer des
conclusions mais depuis l'instauration
de cette mesure le 1er juillet ah ben je
vous dis moi je non j'en tire aucun
bilan
c'est beaucoup trop tôt sur deux mois
juillet août
c'est trop tôt pour le dire je sais même
pas d'ailleurs si l'état a communiqué
des résultats
disons liés à la vitesse sur ces routes
là j'en sais rien en tout cas moi je ne
les ai pas à l'association
je pense que c'est quand même trop tôt
pour tirer des conclusions
et en tant que président du comité des
yvelines directeur du comité divine vous
n'avez pas eu de retour de la part
d'automobilistes sur sur cette mesure
alors moins en mode juillet mois d'août
j'étais en vacances comme tout le monde
donc depuis que j'ai repris le travail
non cette mesure a été présentée comme
une mesure anti oxydants ça veut dire
jean yves petit qu'il faut continuer et
intensifier peut-être le travail sur
d'autres pistes notamment la la lutte
contre l'alcool au volant les la prise
de stupéfiants au volant c'est une piste
aussi c'est un combat dans toutes les
directions bien sûr là il ya eu à l'état
afin le gouvernement a frappé un grand
coup avec la vitesse mais il ya
évidemment d'autres d'autres sujets
abordés vous les avez cités alors
puisque la seule réforme on va on va y
venir aujourd'hui par exemple a été
publié un décret au journal officiel les
automobilistes refusant la priorité un
piéton perdront désormais six points sur
le permis contre quatre auparavant on
parlait justement du danger des piétons
que peuvent avoir les piétons sur la
route c'était nécessaire oui de plus les
protéger sa salle et protège plus
d'après vous cette mesure il ya quand
même eu en 2017
cinq cents
525 à peu près de piétons tués dont la
moitié en agglomération et les piétons
tués dans l'agglomération c'est quand
même essentiellement un choc avec un
véhicule une voiture
donc il y a des choses à faire sans
aucun doute cette mesure qui est
strictement répressive ça ça n'a rien à
voir avec la prévention cette mesure
strictement répressive six points ça
devient quand même très sérieux comme
comme l'alcool comme la drogue quoi donc
ça devient une répression très sévère
trop trop répressif pas passé et
préventive c'est ça vous le dites que ce
je ne sais pas c'est la question
franchement je ne sais rien je ne sais
pas une autre réforme que je voulais
aborder avec vous c'est vous et moi pas
les excuser moi
à moins que vous alliez le dire l'âme
est toujours lié à cette réforme là
dessus la priorité accordée aux piétons
la deuxième mesure qui a été publié
toujours lié à ça c'est que désormais
cette infraction pourraient être
constatés par par vidéo d'accord donc ça
c'est joli ça c'est une évolution
importante avant il fallait qu'il ya un
agent à nos pugilistes voilà constate
l'infraction maintenant ça pourrait être
constatée par vidéosurveillance donc un
outil supplémentaire en tout cas pour
constater ce genre d'infraction alors
autre réforme ce sera à partir du 1er
janvier 2019 le délai probatoire sera
réduit pour les titulaires d'un premier
permis de conduire il faut suivre pour
cela une formation complémentaire entre
le 6e et le 12e mois après obtention du
permis ce que aussi cette mesure et va
dans le bon sens c'est ce qu'elle va
assez loin d'après vous cette mesure
alors là on est franchement dans la
prévention
donc notre association ne peut que
l'approuver en constatant quand même
confort il faudrait pas s'arrêter là il
faudrait aller un peu plus loin
cette mesure est bonne mais elle touche
elle n'est autorisée que pour d
et dans des jeunes conducteurs des
conducteurs novices qui n'ont pas commis
d'infraction donc déjà à priori les bons
et puis comme c'est quelque chose de
volontaire ce qu'ils vont venir
c'est ceux qui sont déjà sensibilisés à
la prévention routière
et puis en plus une question pécuniaire
parce que ça va être payant évidemment
ces sept heures de formation en auto
école
je sais pas du tout combien ça va coûter
mais va peut-être y avoir aussi une
discrimination avec l'argent c'est ça
cette formation elle est à suivre de
nouveau dans une auto-école six mois
après avoir passé son permis on retourne
à l'auto école mais elle est là la
mesure est bonne maintenant faudra
probablement réfléchir aller un peu plus
loin c'est dire qu'on va vers un permis
plus progressif on peut le dire voilà
c'est un peu c'est un peu ça c'est un
peu ça comme ça existe déjà au
luxembourg par exemple où ils ont une
période ça l'est pour le premier permis
un ils ont une période alors appelons-la
probatoire de deux ans au bout de
laquelle il repasse un alors ils suivent
un stage à la fois pratique et théorique
et impôts à l'issue duquel ils ont un
permis de dix ans donc c'est ce qui
existe déjà un peu chez nous cette
progressivité avec les motos vous savez
bien on passe on a d'abord le permis à
a2 pardon à un pardon qui est réel et
125 puis après on peut passer à partir
de 16 ans puis à partir de 18 ans on
peut passer au permis à deux c'est à
dire les grosses motos mais et au
bout de deux ans les motos sont
débridées avec une formation
complémentaire de 7 heures est en passe
au permis illimitée si je puis dire donc
progressivité qui serait peut-être pas
mal de d'étudier aussi pour la voiture
dernière chose il nous reste un peu plus
d'une minute vous le disais tout à
l'heure vous étiez en vacances comme
bouc pour beaucoup la la rentrée pour
l'association prévention routière dans
les yvelines à se passe comment quel
genre d'action vous mener en ce moment
où vous allez mener sur le territoire
abba en ce moment presque tous les jours
de la semaine ce sont les entreprises en
ce moment septembre octobre ce sont les
entreprises qui font appel à nous et
l'éducation nationale on va les laisser
l'on va leur laisser le temps d'absorber
la rentrée et d'éducation nationale
collèges et lycées devraient faire appel
à nous
partir de la fin de l'automne et le
début de l'hiver mais l'élection est
censée restaurer auprès des jeunes de
sensibilisation auprès des jeunes louis
collèges et lycées et oui nous nous
avons régulièrement dans une quinzaine
de collèges et une bonne dizaine de
lycées dans le département on peut
certainement aller encore plus loin mais
c'est déjà pas mal ça fait quelques
milliers d'élèves quand même par an et
nous parlons pour les petits piétons
vélos pour les un tout petit peu plus
grands cyclomoteurs et puis dans les
lycées nous parlons beaucoup alcool
cannabis
merci jean yves petit d'avoir été avec
nous et merci pour ce point complet je
rappelle que vous êtes vous êtes le
directeur du comité et des yvelines de
l'association prévention routière pour
retrouver toutes les informations sur
cette association j'invite les
téléspectateurs à se rendre sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci beaucoup merci la rentrée n'a pas
encore eu lieu pour tout le monde
certains jeunes chinois sont encore en
attente d'une réponse de parcours sup ou
n'ont pas encore trouvé leur voie c'est
notamment pour eux que cette nuit hier
mardi le troisième forum yvelinois de
l'apprentissage à la mairie de
versailles
sur place les jeunes ont pu préciser
leur orientation professionnelle
s'informer des offres d'apprentissage
encore disponibles dans les centres de
formation yvelinoise un retour sur cet
événement avec isabelle karisko échanges
et approfondir et questionner rien de
mieux pour s'orienter que de rencontrer
centre de formation ni employeur pour la
rentrée ces jeunes entre 15 et 30 ans
sont venus nombreux hier au forum
yvelinois de l'apprentissage
j'ai trouvé un
un lycée à saint germain
en laisse et pas très loin de chez moi
et ça m'intéresse parce que parcours
super je suis encore en attente de suez
je pense que du coup bas ce sera pas
possible quoi donc je pense que si je
serais pas venu ici j'aurais pas eu
d'écho
une trentaine d'organismes de formation
en apprentissage
on proposait plus de 600 offres aux
apprentis comme aux employeurs notre
rôle nous c'est trouver les jeunes pour
les entreprises qui viennent nous voir
en disant on veut des apprentis dans tel
ou tel domaine
mais on accompagne aussi les jeunes
contrôlés structure depuis quelques
années des métiers plus atypiques ou au
contraire traditionnels font leur grand
retour
il ya un regain il ya de la demande dans
la boulangerie pâtisserie ya plus de
jeunes qu'avant et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'on a ouvert ses formations qu'on
n'avait pas avant dans notre école parce
que les émissions télé on fait beaucoup
pour de nombreux apprentis c'est
l'occasion d'échanger avec des écoles
mais aussi et surtout avec de nombreux
professionnels présents sur le forum en
venu espère trouver une école est aussi
un patron enfin pourquoi commençons en
bts trouver un patron principale
motivation de cette journée et pour
cause en moyenne 70% des jeunes passés
par l'apprentissage
quant à l'emploi sept mois après la fin
de leur contrat et à l'occasion de ce
forum de l'apprentissage un projet heavy
noah a reçu un chèque de 21 mille euros
ce projet c'est qu'ils feront jobs lancé
par la mission locale de saint germain
en laye qui feront job c'est un site
internet créé par des jeunes pour les
jeunes de 16 à 26 ans une plateforme
collaborative pour partager et trouver
des informations sur les métiers de
demain les formations les entreprises
par le biais du chat et du forum
notamment des propos recueillis par
isabelle caris co aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya un certain nombre de
métiers que les jeunes ne connaissent
pas et l'idée c'est de pouvoir les
sensibiliser à tous ces nouveaux métiers
comme les conducteurs de drones ou
autres métiers un petit peu innovant et
après les avoir sensibilisé va leur
donner des billes sur les formations et
les emplois qui peuvent occuper
on a voulu proposer aux missions locales
un appel à projets ou les jeunes soient
impliqués de a à z sur l'intégralité du
projet pour leur permettre de monter en
compétences à la fois sur le numérique
pour justement travaillé sur cette
fracture numérique et en même temps sur
des compétences transverses qu'on
acquiert lorsqu'on est dans une gestion
de projet le site qui font jobs qui est
d'ores et déjà accessible à l'adresse
suivante tiff ton job point net vous le
savez sûrement la ryder cup débute mardi
prochain pour chacun des six jours de
l'événement près de 60000 spectateurs
sont attendus au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir
mélanie poquet ont fait le point avec
vous sur la circulation pendant
l'événement elle va forcément être
impactés avec un public important qui va
venir sur le territoire alors l'impact
bien sûr mais tout est pensé grégory ses
pensées même depuis 2009 saint quentin
en yvelines a établi un plan de
transport qui a été étudiée que la
fédération française de golf
il y aura deux gars officielle pour
arriver sur le site du golf mais surtout
celle de saint quentin en yvelines celle
qui nous concerne particulièrement on
nous explique où on aura notre gare
routière provisoire avec des dizaines de
navettes qui partiront en direction du
golf national l'a quasiment aucun impact
puisque la venue du centre où se situera
cette gare routière sera toujours
ouverte à la circulation et on aura
simplement deux avenues qui elles vont
être partiellement fermé en l'occurrence
l'avenue de la gare et l'avenue
stephenson alors vous allez le voir sur
les images la venue du centre passera de
deux à une voie et les deux rues fermées
dont on a parlé sont celles qui
encadrent en fait cette fameuse avenue à
noter cependant que les places de
stationnement de ces trois rues seront
fermées puisqu'elles sont destinés à
accueillir les navettes les autres
fermetures concernent les accès proche
du golf national sont concernés là vous
du golfe le chemin de vilains juana
route de l'aéroport et une partie de la
rue de guînes au maire et des avenues de
l'europe et léon blum et quels sont les
conseils de l'agglomération mélanie pour
éviter ces désagréments
alors dans la mesure du possible
saint-quentin devenu conseille d'éviter
le créneau 6
1 9 heures pour les déplacements et de
quitter l'agglomération avant 16h30
et pour retrouver toutes ses
informations un site entrons dans la
légende point fr merci mélanie pour ce
conte d'information cette ryder cup
c'est la troisième compétition sportive
la plus médiatisée au monde si vous
posez vous poser encore des questions
sur ce rendez vous on vous donne toutes
les clés pour la comprendre histoire
format programme est les détails avec
michael et demi d'euros la ryder cup est
aujourd'hui la plus grande compétition
de golf au monde créée en 1927 par
samuel ryder un homme d'affaires anglais
au rendez-vous et aujourd'hui regardés
par un milliard de téléspectateurs à
travers le monde et rassemble près de
250 mille supporters à chaque édition
c'est un roland garros multiplié par 20
c c'est une chance c'est des jeux
olympiques c'est c'est quelque chose que
le public français va probablement avoir
la chance de voir une fois dans sa vie
sur le plan sportif la ryder cup oppose
les 24 meilleurs joueurs au monde 12
européen et douze américains sur trois
jours de compétition le rendez vous est
organisé tous les deux ans en alternance
aux états unis et en europe sur les plus
beaux golfs internationaux cette année
c'est le golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines qui a été à sélectionner
quant aux règles elles sont simples et
indémodable 16 matchs en duo sont
programmées le vendredi et le samedi
dimanche tous les joueurs s'affrontent
en face à face chaque duel rapporte un
point au gagnant un demi point distribué
à chaque joueur pour un match nul la
première équipe à atteindre le score de
14 points et demi est déclaré vainqueur
de la ryder cup en cas d'égalité c'est
l'équipe tenant du titre qui soulève la
coupe au niveau du calendrier un match
entre célébrités européennes et
américaines est programmée le mardi le
mercredi ce sera au junior de
s'affronter dans un match amical le
jeudi une série d'ouvertures est
organisée avec la présentation des
équipes et un concert géant à
compétition débutera officiellement le
vendredi 28 septembre pour se terminer
le 30 septembre avec une remise des
trophées à 18 heures avant de parler
d'autre chose on continue de vous faire
découvrir le parcours de cette ryder cup
2018 aujourd'hui direction le trou
numéro 15 l'un des secteurs les plus
techniques de l'albatros les images de
patrick jacques de dixmude et michael et
demi d'euros
[Musique]
bienvenue on est au départ du trou
numéro 15 a manqué le trou numéro 15 en
fait c'est un trou assez emblématique on
va du parcours l'albatros parce qu'en
fait c'est celui qui va permettre aux
joueurs de rentrer dans l'arène où on va
trouver les quatre derniers trous dont
15 16 17 18 sur lesquels il va se passer
certains ont beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de choses à la fin du mois ce trou
l'hameçon annoncé le juge
c'est un parent par 4 qui fait 373 m
donc ce n'est pas forcément très long
mais qui est quand même assez intimidant
pourquoi parce que les meilleurs du
monde encore une fois parce que le faire
où et quand même relativement étroit
avec l'eau qui est quand même assez
présentes sur sur la partie droite et
leur offre encore une fois très présent
sur la partie gauche
hélas la mise en jeu sera primordiale
pourquoi parce que les vins sont le
partage à battre c'est un parcours sur
lequel la stratégie est prépondérante et
c'est un parcours sur lequel il est
important de réfléchir au coup suivant
hélas le trou numéro 15 le résume camama
c'est bien parce que la mise en jeu sera
comme je le disais primordial avec un
coût qui devrait être quand même
assez assez conséquent assez fort assez
puissant sur la partie gauche du fairway
de façon à ce que le joueur puisse avoir
un petit club pour l'attack de grid ça
reste quand même l'endroit le plus
stressant car la tacc de green sur ce
trou là est vraiment le coup le plus on
va dire le plus oppressant et le plus
stressant que les joueurs vont pouvoir
rencontrer tout au long de ce tournoi
[Musique]
donc là on est sur la position idéale et
après une mise en jeu de façon à pouvoir
attaquer attaquer le green du trou
numéro 15
ici la difficulté c'est ça va être si le
style au drapeau est positionné devant
et à l'entrée du lean pourquoi parce
qu'en fait c'est la partie la plus
étroite
mais c'est un trou également sur lequel
souvent le vent dominant est un vent
avant qui va venir et s'il de la gauche
c'est qui va obligatoirement pousser les
balles qui seront pas très bien contrôlé
et pas très bien touché sur l'obstacle
d'eau qui situe on va dire qui entoure
le green et qui est vraiment très
oppressant sur la partie droite de se
grippe l'autre chose également qu'il
faudra prendre en considération par la
ryder cup c'est c'est la foule qui va y
avoir tout autour de ce trou là parce
que là on est vraiment dans une arena
c'est vraiment une arène golf x1 stadium
c'est tout ce que vous voulez il ya du
monde dans les tribunes no18 dans notre
tribune du 15 les tribunes du trou
numéro un toute la foule qui va pouvoir
entrer ce trou lame très honnêtement je
pense que mon est en capacité ici
d'accueillir à peu près 30 35 mille
spectateurs les 35000 spectateurs qui
vous regardent taper ce coup-là déjà que
quand on le joue sans spectateurs c'est
un trou qui est vraiment très stressant
et très oppressant alors avec toutes ces
paires d'yeux qui vous regardent ça peut
être quelque chose d'assez terrific pour
les joueurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc là on est sur le green du trou
numéro 15 ce green du trou numéro 15 est
assez particulier on va dire parce que
c'était un green qui est à la fois longs
qui est à la fois la quittes entourée
d'eau qui avec énormément de pente
on peut avoir beaucoup de pente au fond
à droite beaucoup de pente devant
également l'entrée du gris sur ce coup
là beaucoup de potes de france se sont
joués on a eu des joueurs qui ont gagné
grâce à des perf où beaucoup de joueurs
camp vidé balle dans l'eau qui sont
retrouvés sur les trois derniers trous
d'air en vue un tournoi passer devant
veut parce que ce trou là les avaient
pénalisé aller pour terminer petit tour
dans nos salles obscures saint
quentinois cette semaine c'est luc
beaucamp du ciné 7 à elancourt qui nous
présente sa sélection elle est à
retrouver à la fiche du cinéma dès
aujourd'hui et les images et l'interview
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
alors dans les salles du ciné set cette
semaine entre autres au film je dis bien
entre autres parce qu'on propose
plusieurs films deux films très
intéressant burning qui est un film
correa qu'un thriller on va dire
sentimentale coréen
qui est qui faisait partie de la
sélection des années festival de cannes
qui a été injustement écarté du palmarès
donc c'est par le réalisateur et poetry
il ya eu le temps dont je vous encourage
vivement à venir découvrir ce film en vo
dans nos salles et à notre film une
comédie comment dirais-je familial on va
dire de cécilia rouaud et avec un
casting exceptionnel jean pierre bacri
notamment pierre de la dhr au chant et
cetera photo de famille donc on reprend
cette semaine dans nos salles c'est une
comédie douce-amère une chronique
familiale autour d'une maman qui va pas
bien et qui va finir par disparaître
malheureusement et on voit les
personnages principaux de cette famille
s'entredéchiraient je sais mais se
retrouver et c'est au fil du temps voilà
donc à voir dans une salle cette semaine
aussi le 7 c'est la fin de cette édition
elle est à revoir tout comme ses
reportages sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile dans un instant
ne manquez pas le retour du 7-8 débat
isabelle caris co cc invités par leur
ont elles de la mise en place du
prélèvement de l'impôt à la source les
entreprises sont elles prêtes pour ce
tournant c'est dans un instant une belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]